Any condition or disease that damages
your heart's ability to pump blood can cause heart failure.
For example, the most common cause is coronary artery disease,
in which blood vessels that supply your
heart muscle, called coronary arteries,
become blocked by a fatty substance called plaque.
Other common causes of heart failure
include:
uncontrolled high blood pressure,
and high blood sugar in diabetes.
Less common causes of heart failure include:
diseased, infected, or damaged heart valves,
irregular heartbeats called arrhythmias,
heart defects,
poisons or substance abuse,
lung diseases,
and breathing problems during sleep called sleep apnea.